die sitzung ist eröffnet
vorab teile ich ihnen mit dass der
ältestenrat in seiner gestrigen sitzung
darauf sich darauf verständigt hat
während der haushaltsberatungen vom 31
mai bis zum dritten juni
2022 wie üblich keine befragung der
bundesregierung keine fragestunde und
keine aktuellen stunden durchzuführen
als präsenztage nach § 14 absatz 1 des
abgeordnetengesetzes werden die tage von
montag dem 30 mai bis freitag dem
dritten juni
2022 festgelegt ich sehe dazu auch
keinen widerspruch dann können wir so
verfahren wir kommen nun zur heutigen
tagesordnung hier habe ich mitzuteilen
dass der tagesordnungspunkt
28 abgesetzt wird
ich rufe nun auf den tagesordnungspunkt
26 beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
auswärtigen ausschusses zu dem antrag
der bundesregierung zur fortsetzung der
beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte an der multidimensionalen
integrierten stabilisierungsmission der
vereinten nationen in mali abgekürzt
heißt das - mal über die
beschlussempfehlung werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache ist eine dauer von 39
minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
aussprache und als erste rednerin hat
das
wort merle spellerberg
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen vor
wenigen wochen durfte ich die
außenministerin auf ihrer reise nach
mali und niger begleiten und eines haben
meine kolleginnen und ich dort immer
wieder gehört sicherheit wir brauchen
sicherheit von der regisseurin in bamako
sicherheit von der schriftstellerin
sicherheit von der
zivilgesellschaftlichen aktivisten in
sicherheit die frauen die ich treffen
durfte wollen und brauchen sicherheit
beim ausüben ihres berufes beim
einkaufen beim weg zum ruhm und das
sicherheit kein ausschließlich
militärisches konzept ist das
diskutieren wir hier im hause seit
wochen seit monaten
aber wenn die frauen die ich in unter
anderem ingo treffen durfte 1 deutlich
gemacht haben dann ist es folgendes es
ist schwer sich sicher zu fühlen wenn
die welt um einen herum von terror von
original von organisierter kriminalität
bestimmt ist die sicherheit der frauen
der männer der kinder aller menschen in
money wiederherzustellen
auch das ist unser interesse
und das ist das mandat dass wir der
bundeswehr für die un mission - mehr
erteilen wollen unser engagement soll
weiter zur stabilisierung des landes
beitragen wir wollen helfen den frieden
zu wahren und menschenrechte zu schützen
und das tun wir nicht kritiklos und die
malische regierung zu schützen in
militärputsch verurteilen wir der
traditions- prozess zur demokratischen
ordnung muss weitergehen
aber in meinen gesprächen mit den
menschen in mali ist klar geworden dass
demokratische wahlen dass kritik an dem
militärputsch nicht ganz oben auf ihrer
agenda steht es ist und bleibt vorerst
sicherheit und das hören wir und das
nehmen wir ernst und
deshalb ist der wichtigste deutsche
auftrag in mali die umsetzung des
friedensabkommens und die wahrung der
menschenrechte
und unsere soldaten in den unser großer
dank gilt unterstützen die einhaltung
dieser waffenruhe wir fördern
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen und helfen
die staatliche integrität
wiederherzustellen
in einem land das von terror und
organisierter gewalt geplagt ist das
höchst fragil ist braucht es diese
staatlichen strukturen umso mehr die un
mission will kriminellen und
terroristischen netzwerken in der region
dadurch auch den nährboden entziehen und
so schaffen wir wichtigen raum für die
arbeit von zivilem personal der un
personal für humanitäre hilfe die
dringend dort ankern muss wo sie
gebraucht wird
das liebe kolleginnen ist also der
grundgedanke dieses einsatzes und dieses
mandat ist ein zeichen für neue
verantwortung eine antwort auf
geostrategische herausforderung wenn die
französischen truppen sich im spätsommer
aus mali zurückziehen dann sind wir dort
der größte truppensteller aus dem
globalen morgen mit 309 soldatinnen
schließen wir die lücke die die
franzosen hinterlassen gerade bei der
rettungskette und dem betrieb des
flughafens
wir haben die nötigen
transporthubschrauber die benötigten
drohnen und diese sind für die umsetzung
des mandates praktisch nicht ersetzbar
und natürlich bedeutet der aufwuchs
gleichzeitig eine enorm gewachsene
verantwortung und diese tragen wir für
die menschen in mali aber auch für
unsere eigenen soldaten
denn was wir nicht haben und das gehört
ehrlichkeit dazu sind die konkurs
straube und die werden fehlen wenn die
franzosen abziehen und das birgt risiken
denn ohne die luft nach unterstützung
sind unsere soldatinnen hörer gefahr
ausgesetzt und gerade deshalb ist die
bundesregierung im engen austausch mit
unseren partner innen und diese
fähigkeiten zu ersetzen denn nur so
können wir den schutz durchgängig
gewährleisten und auch deshalb haben wir
die ausstiegsklausel im mandat meinen
vollen abzug zu ermöglichen wenn die
sicherheitslage nichts anderes mehr
erlauben sollte und natürlich muss ein
deutscher beitrag in - man auch im
kontext der anderen akteure in mali
gesehen werden wir wissen dass russische
kräfte der wagner gruppe vor ort sind
wir wissen dass sie schwere
menschenrechtsverstöße begehen und dass
die militär und mit ihnen
zusammenarbeitet und wir wissen auch
dass diese zusammenarbeit zugenommen hat
die gezielte russischen
desinformationskampagne die unseren
französischen partnern kriegsverbrechen
anhängen wollen können und werden wir
nicht akzeptieren und
auch besser sollten wir alles daran tut
jetzt nicht zu weich als
weltgemeinschaft ist es ein anliegen die
länder im sahel zu stabilisieren und
nicht der russischen propaganda zu
überlassen
marlies regierung ist dabei sich im
russischen geostrategischen kalkül zu
verfangen und darunter wird am ende die
zivilgesellschaft leiden und auch das
hat die außenministerin auf unserer
reise deutlich gemacht um auf die
zivilgesellschaft zurückzukommen ich
möchte mich für die frauen in der die
menschen in mali einsetzen die gerade in
unsicherheit leben denn nur und darum
geht es am ende nur aus sicherheit
heraus kann sich stabilität für
demokratische wahlen entwickeln nur aus
sicherheit kann sich freiheit entwickeln
und wenn wir hierzu beitragen können
dann sollten wir das tun und das können
wir durch die beteiligung der bundeswehr
an - und deswegen liebe kolleginnen
empfehle ich dieses mandat zu
unterstützen
merle spellerberg aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen hat die debatte
eröffnet die abschließende debatte über
den bundeswehr einsatz der vereinten
nationen in mali eine gute halbe stunde
wird debattiert dann wird namentlich
abgestimmt werden sie werden in den
nächsten minuten häufiger hören den die
abkürzung - made steht für die
multidimensionale
integrierte stabilisierungsmission der
un in mali nächster redner es nur an
wadephul aus der unionsfraktion
ja meine verantwortung für diese region
die gefunden ist die leidet der
überbevölkerung unterernährung
terrorismus europa deutschland hat eine
verantwortung für die sache region die
nehmen wir wahr und deswegen unterstützt
die cdu csu fraktion den antrag der
bundesregierung dort wird heute
zustimmen wir
unterstützen damit auch die vereinten
nationen un in dieser weltpolitischen
lage wir diskutieren viele andere
regionen der welt hier im ausschuss oder
in den ausschüssen und natürlich auch
hier im plus deutschen bundestages man
müsste ja die vereinten nationen
geradezu jetzt erfinden wenn es sie
nicht schon gäbe und deswegen ist jeder
einsatz den wir gerade im einst im raum
der vereinten nationen machen ein
besonders wertvoller und es ist jeden
einsatz deutschlands werden die
vereinten nationen zu stärken es gibt
genug nationen die die vereinten
nationen schwächen wollen sie
unterminieren wollen eine eigene regel
ordnung aufsetzen wollen das ist nicht
unsere politik wir sind der
internationalen regelbasierten ordnung
verpflichtet dieser einsatz manifestiert
dass und deswegen ist es gut wenn es
eine breite mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag gibt diesen einsatz in mali
und in der sahelzone fortzusetzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe dann
auf einige anmerkungen zum verfahren und
zum inhalt unseres engagement für die
zukunft das eine betrifft das verfahren
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und das möchte ich den kollegen den
kollegen waren wir haben einige zeit im
ersten ausschuss zusammengearbeitet
schon normal in aller ernsthaftigkeit
sagen den mandatstext haben wir zwei
stunden vor der ersten lesung bekommen
wir waren in den fraktionen in den
arbeitsgruppen in unserer gesamtfraktion
nicht in der lage vor der beratung des
ausschusses
zu informieren wie dieses mandat unter
welchen umständen ford geben sollte und
sie alle wissen dass die ausschuss
debatte entscheidend dafür ist dass wir
alle fraktionskolleginnen und kollegen
darüber unterrichten unter welchen
obwaltenden umständen die
bundesregierung gedenkt den einsatz
fortzusetzen
das bundestags beteiligungsgesetz ist
kein bundes kennt erkenntnis gerade
gesetz und wir erwarten von der
kollektion in zukunft eine andere einen
anderen umgang mit dem parlament in tote
ich setze voraus dass auch ihre
kolleginnen ein interesse daran haben
fachgerecht informiert zu werden und ich
denke so was darf sich in zukunft nicht
wiederholen
das zweite
auch dabei könnte man klatscht und würde
nicht leicht die koalition verraten wenn
man das vielleicht sogar teilt bisschen
legten habe ich in ihren reihen gesehen
dass das
dass das zweite ist und das möchte ich
in aller ernsthaftigkeit sagen frau
steiner ich kann ihre ausführungen fast
vollständig teilen das ist sehr sehr
erfreulich und das tun wir auch gerne
sie haben mit einem kurzen satz die
rückzugs klausel erwähnt die wir im
ausschuss im verteidigungsausschuss
vertieft haben und das möchte ich schon
noch mal dazu sagen wir müssen mal
wissen worum es hier geht
verteidigungsministerin hat im ausschuss
besagt dass ein vollständiger rückzug
unserer kräfte möglich ist wenn ein
ersatz der kräfte die die franzosen
jetzt stellen nicht gewährleistet ist
und zugleich wurde uns signalisiert dass
man etwa damit rechnet dass im august
ein abzug der französischen kräfte
erfolgt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren regen wir ernsthaft heute über
ein mandat das die bundesregierung
gedenkt schon im august wieder
vollständig zu beenden wollen sie
ernsthaft im august über 1000
soldatinnen und soldaten aus diesem
un-einsatz ich hab was zur un gesandten
zurückziehen hals über kopf die un mit
wichtigen aufklärungskräfte frau
kollegin sie haben darauf hingewiesen
sozusagen ohne diese aufklärungskräfte
zurücklassen ich kann nur sagen was ist
eine abenteuerliche vorstellung frau
lambrecht und das was sie dazu im
verteidigungsausschuss gezeigt gesagt
haben zeigt einmal mehr dass die der
ratschlag unseres fraktionsvorsitz an
die an den bundeskanzler mehr als
angemessen war so geht es nicht entweder
wir stimmen hier ein mann dazu wo auch
die vereinten nationen sich darauf
verlassen können dass deutsche kräfte in
dieser stärke
stärkste mandats kraft vor ort für ein
jahr verlässlich vor ort ist oder wir
stimmen den man darf nicht zu wir müssen
uns darauf verlassen können dass die
bundesregierung alles daran setzt dass
das mandat ein erhalten werden kann dass
es ihre hausaufgabe die geben wir ihnen
mit
ich will das in aller ernsthaftigkeit
sagen ja das ist dass das ist nicht ein
spannendes konstrukte kollege lechte das
ist kein spannendes konstrukt sondern
man weiß seit man weiß seit februar dass
die franzosen sich definitiv
zurückziehen und diejenigen die wie sie
sehr informiert sind über die gesamte
lage vor ort und das verhältnis zwischen
der malischen regierung und der
französischen regierung konnten auch
schon vorher davon ausgehen dass das
geschehen würde also das ist keine sache
die man vom himmel gefallen ist und es
wäre die aufgabe der
verteidigungsministerin gewesen sich
darum zu kümmern und darum müssen wir
jetzt auch diese zeit müssen wir nutzen
und da bitte ich nur für meine fraktion
auch die zusammenarbeit und die
diskussion in den fachausschüssen und
auch darüber hinausgehend in den
nächsten monaten an wir brauchen jetzt
auch eine strategie für diese region und
das dilemma ist ja auch richtig
beschrieben worden frau spellerberg ich
teile das natürlich müssen wir weiterhin
die sicherheitspolitische voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass in dieser region
insbesondere in staat mali eine
demokratische entwicklung stattfinden
kann eine soziale entwicklung
stattfinden kann dass frauen aber auch
alle anderen menschen sich sicher
bewegen können und da brauchen wir einen
erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff
vollkommen eindeutig natürlich dürfen
wir nicht zulassen dass die russen damit
wagner kräften einfluss gewinnen und
natürlich müssen wir den internationalen
terrorismus bekämpfen dafür braucht es
eine gesamtstrategie die viel fehlt
bisher und darum sollten wir uns alle
bemühen herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
johann wadephul einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
unionsfraktion
signalisiert die zustimmung seiner
friedhöfe seiner fraktion zum un einsatz
der bundeswehr in mali erwartet aber
auch eine gesamtstrategie für die
nächste zeit und darauf kann jetzt
direkt der wieder nils schmid der
außenpolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion
zunächst einmal bin ich der
cdu/csu-fraktion dankbar dass sie diesen
einsatz unterstützt das ist gut dass wir
in diesen fragen wo die bundeswehr ins
ausland entsendet wird möglichst breite
unterstützung aus der mitte des hauses
erfahren
ich bin aber etwas verwundert kollege
waren über ihre aussage zu dem mandat
und der frage eines möglichen abzugs der
bundeswehr
denn umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus sie
wollen doch nicht ernsthaft als cdu csu
fraktion den einsatz fortsetzen wenn die
sicherheit und die medizinische
versorgung unserer soldaten
gewährleistet
das geht ja hier nicht um ein abstraktes
beginn ist zu einer un-mission natürlich
will diese bundesregierung wie auch die
vorangegangenen bundesregierungen die
arbeit der un stärken und insbesondere
auch bei einer der größten
friedensmissionen der un unterstützung
leisten aber wenn unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten in gefahr sind weil die
medizinische versorgung mangels
transportkapazitäten nicht mehr
ausreichend gewährleistet ist im
krisenfall dann müssen wir konsequenzen
ziehen das ist unsere aufgabe als mal
parlamentarier für unsere bundeswehr
und deshalb gibt es diese
ausstiegsklausel in dem mandat sowie von
der bundesregierung
vorgeschlagen und vorgelegt und wir
bekennen uns ausdrücklich dazu dass wir
die bundeswehrsoldaten abziehen müssen
wenn diese sicherheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist
ich will aber auch deutlich sagen dass
der manie einsatz einmal mehr den engen
zusammenhang zwischen sicherheit und
entwicklung aufzeigt ohne sicherheit
keine entwicklung ohne
entwicklung aber auch keine nachhaltige
sicherheit und deshalb schon seit jahren
dieser einsatz der bundeswehr im marli
auch ein testfall für den vernetzten
ansatz denn die konfliktlagen die
problemlage marlies in vielfacher sind
vor allem soziale
verteilungskonflikte verschärft durch
die veränderung des klimas in der
sahel-zone insgesamte sind ökologische
konflikte und es sind ungelöste
politische konflikte vor allem die
mangelhaft der vertretung der jungen
generation im politischen system
verstärkt durch politische
fehlentwicklung der letzten jahre dass
auch in mali die regierung auf den
einsatz von milizen gesetzt hat in der
vergangenheit die ebenfalls schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen der
bezichtigt worden sind dass jetzt die
wagner miliz dazugekommen ist ebenfalls
mit schweren menschenrechtsverletzung
dass wale nicht durchgeführt werden und
wenn sie durchgeführt werden nicht auf
ausreichende akzeptanz
stoßen weil eben nicht alle
bevölkerungsgruppen
abgebildet werden die demilitarisierung
und wiedereinführung wir was mit der
kämpfer geht schleppend voran und der
zivile schub denn auf dem gipfel von
samina im sinne von entwicklung der
schaffung von inseln der stabilität
versprochen worden ist geht auch sehr
zögerlich und schwerfällig voran also
eine durchaus schwierige
gesamtgemengelage wo aber gerade diese -
mission zentrale stabilisierungs
funktionen warmen und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir heute 23 tun im deutschen
bundestag dort wo es nicht gut läuft
nämlich bei der ausbildungsmission haben
wir den mut einen klaren schnitt zu
machen und zwar nicht länger zu warten
sondern diesen schnitt heute und jetzt
zu machen nachdem die putschisten die
grundlage für die zusammenarbeit
entzogen haben und gleichzeitig bekennen
wir uns zur arbeit der vereinten
nationen zur stabilisierungsarbeiten für
- zur unterstützung des
friedensabkommens von algier und
natürlich auch zur absicherung der
großen und beträchtlichen deutschen
entwicklungshilfe
die in maria weiterhin gewährleistet
werden soll deshalb ist für uns diese -
tradition eine die im sinne des
vernetzten ansatzes das richtige tut
deshalb sind wir auch bereit
fähigkeitslücken zu schließen sofern die
bundeswehr selber fähigkeiten zusätzlich
einbringen kann aber es ist eine
uno-mission deshalb ist auch die gesamte
uno in der verantwortung ausreichend
technische fähigkeiten für diese mission
zu entsenden und es ist eben nicht
aufgabe der bundeswehr und das können
wir auch gar nicht alle lücken zu
schließen die seit jahren beklagt werden
sondern das ist eine aufgabe der
gesamten weltgemeinschaft und in diesem
sinne ist die bundesregierung auch im
gespräch die lippen bei den fähigkeiten
für transporter
für den transport hubschrauber zu
schließen
wir wissen dass der prozess in mali
mühselig sein wird aber ohne bahnen eine
ausreichend
solide wählerregistrierung im vorfeld
warnen die auch neuen kräften die
möglichkeit
eröffnen sich an diesem demokratischen
prozess zu beteiligen ohne ein
mindestmaß an
demokratischen institutionen die mali
werden wir auch die zugrunde liegenden
ökonomischen und gesellschaftlichen
konflikte nicht lösen können und ist mir
ganz wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass der
ansatz den wir in mali fahren nicht
aussichtslos ist denn mali hat auch
schon lange phasen demokratische
regierung erlebt ja eine lebendige
zivilgesellschaft wir haben
institutionen die man aufbauen kann auf
die man setzen kann und deshalb ist es
aller mühen wert von uns im deutschen
bundestag von der bundesregierung der
bundeswehr aber auch dem zivilen
engagement diese unterstützung für
dieses land über - mal weiter zu leisten
ich danke all denjenigen bei der
bundeswehr und in der entwicklungshilfe
tätigen die sich weiterhin in diesem
land engagieren und selbstverständlich
wird die spd zustimmt herzlichen dank
nils schmid war dass der außenpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion hat auch am
ende nochmal gesagt erst für die
fraktion wird zustimmen das ganze wird
in gut 20 minuten dann sein dass die
abstimmung hier in der west lobby
eröffnet werden wird aber vorher haben
wir noch reserven leute aus der afg
fraktion unter anderem sehr geehrte
damen und herren das mandat das sie
heute zur abstimmung vorliegt ist ja
wirklich mal bemerkenswert schon in den
ersten sätzen steht ja darin dass es
vielleicht gar nicht funktionieren wird
und wie es frühzeitig werden beenden
müssen die bundesregierung hat
offensichtlich kein vertrauen in das
eigene mandat aber wir sollen heute auf
dieser grundlage schon mal 1400 deutsche
soldaten nach mali entsenden die
alternative für deutschland wird das
sicher nicht mitmachen
und ich will mal zwei argumente
aufgreifen die von den befürwortern
dieses mandates des öfteren genannt
werden das eine ist dass wir nicht
abziehen könnten aus mali war ja ein
vakuum entstanden und das mag ja sogar
sein in dem winzigen teil x iks den wir
irgendwie kontrollieren da könnte ein
vakuum entstehen aber dieses argument
das können wir doch nur gelten lassen
wenn die bundesregierung uns ein konzept
vorlegt mit dem sich das perspektivisch
mal ändert dass irgendwann mal der tag
kommt an dem wir unsere soldaten aus
mali wieder abziehen können und kein
vakuum mehr entsteht ein solches konzept
bleibt die bundesregierung uns aber
schuldig so dass es heute im kern darum
geht 1400 bundeswehr-soldaten nach mali
zu schicken damit sie dort ausharren und
wie einfach mal das beste rocken und
hoffen dass sich einer findet der die
luftunterstützung bereitstellt dass es
verantwortungslos gegenüber unseren
soldaten die stimme mit nein heute
und der andere punkt ja manchmal genannt
wird ist das migrationsbewegungen
anfangen können von mali aus nach
deutschland wenn wir abziehen würden
oder auch dass terroristen vielleicht
herüber kommen da gibt es eine relativ
einfache lösung liebe bundesregierung
machen sie ihren job kontrollieren sie
wer ein wandert nach deutschland
schützen sie die grenzen dass es ihr
auftrag nicht der unserer soldaten
und ich will mal ein paar zahlen denn
zumal weil ja alles so toll läuft wie
man hier im haus schließen könnte aus
ihren reden die sie erhalten haben 2013
fing der einsatz an das stand mali auf
den globalen terrorismus index auf platz
19 vier jahre später 2017 stand mali auf
platz zehn und heute steht mali auf
platz sieben des globalen terrorismus
index diese verschlechterung konnten wir
nicht verhindern 2020 gab es 393 terror
tote in mali ein jahr später
574 dass eine erhöhung von 46%
terrororganisationen in not und zentral
mali rekrutieren so erfolgreich neue
kämpfer wie nie zuvor - meist der
gefährlichste un-einsatz mit 272 toten
zwei davon waren bundeswehrsoldaten wir
reden hier über ein land das dreieinhalb
mal so groß wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland und die regierung meint mit
300 zusätzlichen soldaten könnten wir
hier irgendetwas bewegen während gerade
fünf tausend französische soldaten aus
mali wieder abziehen ich habe einen
vorschlag für alle die meinen wir müssen
da deutsche soldaten jetzt hinschicken
gehen sie in die nächste kaserne
empfangen sie sich in g36 setzten sich
ein helm auf und dann fliegen sie selbst
nach malibu lassen unsere soldaten aus
der nummer mal raus
nächster gegner für die fdp fraktion
ulrich lechte der außenpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dieser versuch des latenten vorwurf dass
wir leichtfertig soldaten in missionen
entsenden ist eine bodenlose frechheit
weil wirklich auf wochen und monate
darüber diskutieren
und der grund warum wir dass man da zu
spät vorgelegt haben waren dass wir
darum gerungen haben die beste variante
ihnen allen hier im haus vorlegen zu
können weil dieses mandat so schwierig
ist
nein die schlechteste variante ist dass
sie überhaupt in dieses haus gewählt
wurden aber da müssen wir weiter mit
gegen
den kollegen wadephul
möchte ich entgegnen
ich weiß es ist ein sehr sehr schwerer
prozess in der opposition die rolle zu
finden und ich bin sehr dankbar dass die
union auch heute diesem mandat zustimmt
und dass wir in vielen vielen aspekten
die wir momentan behandeln müssen auch
im auswaertigen miteinander kooperieren
und zu gemeinsamen lösungen kommen siehe
der ukraine antrag siehe die mandate die
unsere bundeswehr betreffen
und ist gerade die sicherheit der
soldaten wichtig wir wissen was dort
unten passiert und deswegen haben wir
alle möglichkeiten in diesem mandat
angelegt dass wir auch zurück zu
beordern können haben der
bundesregierung die möglichkeit gegeben
je nachdem wie sich die lage für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten im marli
entwickelt das ist der grund warum das
man dazu angelegt ist sie wissen auch
dass gewisse komponenten fehlen die wir
selber als bundeswehr derzeit nicht in
ausreichender menge zur verfügung
die kampfhubschrauber
wir haben davon mehr das ist bekannt
nämlich über 50 und s inhalt momentan
nur 9 danke herr partner für den
zwischenruf ich weiß es selber 9 nur
einsatzfähig ich meine ich muss dazu zur
kenntnis nehmen dass wir 16 jahre
verantwortung für die bundeswehr leider
bei der union hatten das ist halt nun
mal historischer politischer fakt und
wir müssen uns jetzt damit beschäftigen
dass alles zum fliegen zu bringen so wie
es der bundeskanzler auch gesagt hat wir
müssen die sachen zum schwimmen bringen
wir müssen die sachen zum fliegen
bringen wir brauchen munition und das
muss ausgerechnet eine koalition machen
wo die grünen mit ihren großen friedens
anteil dabei sind und die spd und hier
hat das nicht hinbekommt wir als fdp
unterstützen das natürlich deswegen
brauchen wir auch die zustimmung von
euch für die 100 milliarden welche
überraschung ja deswegen die ganzen
politischen diskussionen können wir uns
hier im haus schenken wenn wir nicht den
realitäten uns stellen die realität ist
dass wir plötzlich einer wünscht
plötzlicher wir haben ein aggressor an
der ostflanke wie das so schön heute
erneut wieder heißt und dafür müssen wir
gemeinsam streiten und die kommentare
mal weglassen da freue ich mich sowieso
schon auf die rede die gleich kommen
wird ich hoffe dass du eine kollege von
der spd dass entsprechend verfrühstücken
werden kann aber wir diskutieren hier
heute - mali als dem bis vor kurzem
wichtigsten einsatz der deutschen
bundeswehr im ausland und in mali sind
nicht nur wagner
seltener aus russland sondern das sind
offizielle russische truppen
hätten wir deswegen aber jetzt gesagt
wir gehen dort raus dann hätte man ohne
probleme immer mal wieder 1 2 300
soldaten von russland in irgendwelche
krisengebiete entsenden und daraufhin
hätte sich der westen seiner
verantwortung
entzogen das dürfen wir nicht machen und
damit dass hier auch mal gesagt wird im
hause
wir sind neben den problemen die die
franzosen mit der malischen regierung
haben und die malische regierung ist
wahrlich nicht einfach ich war dabei wie
die außenministerin mit dem präsidenten
weiter diskutiert und gesprochen hat
aber wir sind ja nicht der 1 sieht das
einzige land auf gottes erdboden in
diesem haus sich vorstellen könnte dort
gibt es viele kleinere truppensteller
auch die in diesem mandat mit dabei sind
und die sich auf uns verlassen und dazu
gehören unter anderem belgien estland
litauen und die niederlande als unsere
europäischen partner vor ort aber auch
große truppensteller wie bangladesch
burkina faso der niger senegal togo und
die elfenbeinküste
multinational und die verlassen sich auf
das großartige deutsche kontingent auf
unsere fähigkeiten die wir dort unten
stellen und dass wir mit ihnen zusammen
für die sicherheit sorgen und ich habe
in der letzten debatte schon gesagt dass
ich mittlerweile über 30.000 menschen
mehr befinden als zu beginn des
konfliktes und die vertrauen darauf dass
wir dort sind wenn am ende des tages ist
aber nicht mehr funktionieren sollte und
die grundlagen für die sicherheit
unserer soldatinnen soldaten nicht
gewährt ist dann hat die bundesregierung
mit diesem mandat die möglichkeit
abzuziehen und gleichzeitig haben wir in
das mandat geschrieben dass der
bundestag von der bundesregierung einen
bericht bekommt jeder zeit wenn wir das
wünschen wir haben also auch noch eine
weitere komponente
neben evaluierung die berichte für uns
alle als parlamentarier da drin deswegen
bitte ich um zustimmung ein besseres
mandat und die massive defizite das
mandat hat es lange in diesem haus nicht
mehr gegeben vielen dank ulrich rechte
der
außenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion in der debatte in der es noch
einmal geht um die verlängerung des
bundeswehreinsatzes in mali hintergrund
ist eine un mission wir hören ali al
dailami aus der linksfraktion den
konnten heute morgen schon bei uns sehen
das interview mit simplem müller
selbstverständlich war unsere auf
unserer youtube-seite auf unserer
homepage noch mal nach im rahmen des
einsatzes - mal in mali gegenwärtig sind
knapp über 1000 soldatinnen und soldaten
vor ort und heute nach neun jahren kann
man feststellen dieser einsatz ist
krachend gescheitert so gut wie keines
der verkündeten ziel wurde erreicht
schlimmer noch die lage nicht nur in
mali sondern in der gesamten sahel zone
ist völlig eskaliert und diese mission
entwickelt sich immer mehr zu einem
kriegseinsatz mit undurchsichtigen
folgen und für diese folgen tragen auch
sie meine damen und herren von der
bundesregierung die mitverantwortung
bisher
272 un-soldaten bei diesem einsatz ums
leben gekommen ist es somit einer der
verlustreichsten un einsätze seit dem
koreakrieg in den 1950 er jahren und
seit beginn dieses einsatzes sind
tausende menschen getötet und millionen
vertrieben worden gleichzeitig haben
sich die anschläge terroristischer
gruppierungen mehr als vervierfacht doch
anstatt sich das scheitern einzugestehen
und die soldatinnen und soldaten endlich
nach hause zu holen wollen sie
stattdessen weitere 300 in das
pulverfass mali in senden es sage ihnen
das ist nichts anderes als die
fortsetzung des bisherigen scheiterns
mit ansage das ist verantwortungslos und
daran werden wir uns nicht beteiligen
meine damen und herren
und wenn man sich ihren antragstext mal
so durchliest dann steht da unter
anderem als auftrag für diesen einsatz
unter punkt 3 ich darf zitieren
unterstützung für die
unterstützung für die umsetzung des
abkommens für frieden und aussöhnung in
mali und b die unterstützung bei der
wiederherstellung der staatlichen
autorität zitat ende das ist deshalb
erwähnenswert weil es sich hier ja schon
erwähnt um das friedensabkommen von alge
aus dem jahre 2015 zwischen der
damaligen malischen regierung und zwei
jahre rebellengruppen handelt ganze
sechs mal berufen sie sich heute in
ihren anträgen genau auf diesen
friedensschluss das problem ist nur
dieses abkommen hat mittlerweile
jegliche grundlage verloren denn es gab
zwei putsche in mali seitdem die 2 der
zweite unterzeichnung dieses abkommens
wurde mittlerweile ermordet die dritte
unterstützergruppe wie dach und gar
nichts mehr wissen paktiert mittlerweile
mit der al qaida und verdient ihr geld
mit drogen und menschenhandel und in
anbetracht dieser fakten reden sie auch
noch ernsthaft in ihren antrag davon das
abkommen von algier umsetzen und die
staatliche autorität wiederherstellen zu
wollen meine damen und herren von der
regierung dass es an absurdität und
realitätsfremd kaum zu überbieten
deshalb kommen sie zurück in die
realität ziehen sie die soldatinnen und
soldaten endlich ab
und zu allerletzt
zweieinhalb milliarden euro haben sie
bisher nur für das militärische dieses
einsatzes regelrecht verpulvert sie
können sich ja mal fragen wie viel leid
elend und hunger hält man mit nur einem
bruchteil dieses geldes verhindern
können danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
ali al dailami für die linksfraktion im
verkehrs florian hahn cdu/csu
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher
von präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
richtig ist die sicherheitslage in mali
verschlechtert sich und sie ist prekär
und ende juni läuft das mandat der
vereinten nationen aus und kenntnisse
über eine substanzielle verbesserung
des freien mandats haben wir nicht und
aufgrund der französisch des
französischen rückzugs entstehen die
bereits genannten fähigkeitslücken und
nach dem rückzug weiterer partner
verbleibt deutschland als einzige
größere
europäischen nationen bei - man eine
perspektive
mit klaren zielen ist weder bei der em
noch bei der bundesregierung zu sehen
und auch die beiträge von frau
spellerberg herrn nächte und herren
schmidt haben dazu nicht wirklich
beigetragen das vakuum
das durch die französischen dass durch
den französischen abzug entsteht wird in
den umkämpften gebieten vermutlich
schnell durch nichtstaatliche und
terroristische akteure gefüllt werden
die bundesregierung konnte uns auch
nicht schlüssig darlegen die
terrorbekämpfung zukünftig durchgeführt
werden soll folglich wird diese
gefährliche mission noch gefährlicher
werden das mandat versucht deswegen
lücken
vorrangig durch ein mehr an personal zu
schließen diese generieren aber nicht
ein mehr an fähigkeiten für die mission
sie sind auch nicht ausreichend um die
sicherheitslage in der region zu
verbessern beziehungsweise die
politischen ziele des einsatzes
tatsächlich zu erreichen und die musste
deswegen feststellen die mission hat
keinen ziel zustand keine realistische
bewertung des machbaren und vor allem
keine evolution der wirksamkeit der
mission und des bundeswehreinsatzes
der wirkungsradius der deutschen
soldaten für die zentrale aufgabe dem
schutz der zivilbevölkerung wird auch
das umfeld des campus und entsprechend
begrenzt seien und weiterhin frage ich
mich für wen die aufklärungsergebnisse
wirksam genutzt werden können wenn keine
wird mittel mehr da sind und niemand mit
diesen aufklärungs ergebnissen im
anschluss arbeitet
aufklärungsergebnisse für die unsere
soldaten entsprechen ihr leben riskieren
und die bundesregierung hat sich aber
scheinbar bei den vn und anderen partner
nationen nicht durchsetzen können sie
ist also nicht in der lage gewesen die
relevanz und die perspektiven gegenüber
den partnern zu erklären und deswegen
stelle ich fest dass mandate ist
schlecht durch die bundesregierung
vorbereitet und auch den letzten drücker
zusammengestellt worden die
ausstiegsklausel es dafür signifikant
sie ist ein zeichen für die schlechte
vorbereitung
die eigene unsicherheit die fehlenden
perspektiven und absprachen und deswegen
kann ich nur sagen da helfen auch alle
anderen ablenkungsmanöver nicht wir
fordern als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
dass die roten linien für den einsatz
unserer soldaten fortlaufend bewertet
und im parlament berichtet werden und
sollten die voraussetzungen für einen
einsatz nicht mehr gegeben sein müssen
konsequenzen gezogen werden die
entsprechenden szenarien und planungen
müssen vorbereitet wird es ist völlig
unverantwortlich kolleginnen und
kollegen der afd das was sie fordern
nämlich von heute auf morgen über 1000
bundeswehrsoldaten und soldaten einfach
so abzuziehen das wäre wohl mit größten
mit größter gefahr für dieselben
verbunden und es wäre im übrigen auch
mit blick auf die sechs nationen die
sich dort verlassen und verantwortlich
aber ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich wir die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion stimmen nur
mit größten bauchschmerzen dazu wir
tragen das mandat nur mit weil wir
verantwortung für diese region haben
aber noch vielmehr weil wir es unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten schuldig sind
sie bei dieser immer schwieriger
werdenden mission zu unterstützen
das geschieht zum schutze um den
geordneten rückbau zu ermöglichen und
die truppe dabei den verdienten breiten
parlamentarischen rückhalt zu geben
herzlichen dank
florian a csu und
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion nicht ganz zufrieden mit
der mandats beschreibung wie die
verlängerung des einsatzes zur folge
haben soll letzter redner in dieser
aussprache pardon ist christoph schmidt
noch einmal spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen in
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
lassen sie es mich gleich zu beginn sehr
deutlich machen ja wie als abgehört
tragen eine hohe verantwortung für das
wohl unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
den ich an dieser stelle für den einsatz
sehr herzlich danke
und vielen dank an den kollegen rechte
für die geduld als nachhilfelehrer für
die rechte seite des hauses ich dachte
ich müsste es für die linke übernehmen
jetzt muss ich für nachdem haben auch
noch ein bisschen übernehmen es ist ein
un mandat und wir bewegen uns in einem
internationalen rahmen und einzigen
aufgepasst hätten dann steht das
entweder mandatstext oder wir haben uns
die evaluierung im koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen wir gehen mit dieser
verantwortung sehr sehr viel möglich
und deshalb danke ich ausdrücklich auch
der bundesregierung dafür dass alle
anregungen aus den intensiven beratungen
der letzten wochen und monate in diesen
mandatstext jetzt mit eingeschlossen
sind über den wir heute abstimmen
dadurch findet nämlich auch der schutz
der soldatinnen und soldaten die
erforderliche berücksichtigen wie
bereits erwähnt emission muss - man hat
mehrere sollen es heute friedensvertrag
und als gesichert werden die zufrieden
war und ist brüchig und dennoch ist
diese friedensvertrag das grundsätzliche
gerüst für ein friedliches zusammenleben
es ist besser einen brüchigen frieden zu
schützen als einen heißen krieg zu
riskieren
zweitens einmal die zivilbevölkerung
geschützt werden leib und leben von
kindern frauen und männern zu schützen
und die präsenz von internationalen
kräften ein leben ohne angst zu
ermöglichen das ist doch ein sich selbst
erklären das ziel die meisten von uns
wissen nicht aus eigener erfahrung wie
es ist in einem uns ihren krisengebiet
leben zu müssen wir leben in sicherheit
was wir aber tun können tun müssen ist
den menschen in der sahelzone etwas mehr
sicherheit und angstfreiheit zu
garantieren die internationale präsenz
im land wird von der lokalen bevölkerung
sehr begrüßt - man genießt hohe
zustimmung in den regionen den - aktiv
ist ja und - und das wurde auch schon
erwähnt ist auch ein garant für die
absicherung der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und damit für
die zukunft im saal wir wissen alle dass
die menschen eine zukunftsperspektive
brauche deutschland ist ein willkommener
und zuverlässige partner das haus von
ministerin svenja schulze koordiniert
die mali zahlreiche wichtige initiativen
und viele die es initiativen ja viele
wichtige projekte sind ohne ein
mindestmaß an sicherheit und dass er
zwar später bei gewohnt einfach nicht
durchführbar mit unserer zugesagt mit
heiliger - mal sorgen wir dafür dass
diese wertvollen projekte weitergeführt
werden
wir zeigen aber auch die gemeinschaft
dass deutschland bereit ist
verantwortung im rahmen der verein zu
übernehmen und hier nun die gewünschte
ansage an die ganz linke seite des
hauses internationale verantwortung
bedeutet eben nicht dass man der uno
einen kriegseinsatz unterstellt
mit der begebung der personalobergrenze
unterstützen wir den ausgleich bisher
von frankreich übernommen und
fähigkeiten vor allem im bereich der
sanitätsdienstlichen einrichtung als das
nennen sie kriegerisch in welcher welt
leben sie denn finden sie wirklich dass
das die realität ich bin froh dass meine
realität anders aussehen aber
mit formulieren im süden unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten auch
bedingungen an die vn und diese
ausstiegs pausenlos die bereits mehrfach
erwähnt damit auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger wissen worüber wir sprechen darf
ich das zitieren sofern während des
mandats zeitraums ein ausreichendes
schutzniveau für deutsche soldatinnen
und soldaten nicht mehr gewährleistet
werden kann es sind maßnahmen zur
anpassung des deutschen beitrags
einzuleiten bis hin zur beendigung des
einsatzes dies betrifft insbesondere die
fortgesetzte verfügbarkeit von
luftunterstützung nach dem abzug der
französischen kampfhubschraubern
ich bin der verteidigungsminister in
christine lambrecht sehr dankbar dass
sie im ausschuss noch einmal sehr klar
dargestellt hat wie wichtig auch hier
dieser punkt ist sie hat in vielen
gesprächen bis zuletzt versucht eine
lösung mit anderen nationen zu finden
und wird sich dort auch weiter
einbringen aber
aber und das sollten auch die kollegen
von der union wissen die sicherstellung
des anteils der luft nach unterstützung
an der mission ist nicht die originäre
aufgabe der deutschen
verteidigungsminister in sondern die
aufgabe der vereinten nationen
wir zeigen den vereinen nationen dass
wir zur verantwortungsübernahme bereit
sind aber wir ziehen zum schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten auch eine klare
grenze wir formulieren einen klaren
arbeitsauftrag an die uno und ich gehe
davon aus erwartet dass wir uns da einig
sind sie haben über die uno gesprochen
die uno ist bestimmt nicht perfekt aber
sie ist das beste mittel zum
multinationalen konfliktbeilegung dass
wir haben und es liegt an den einzelnen
nationen dass wir die uno verbessern
lassen sie uns gilt die zustimmung zum
veränderten mandat - man signalisieren
dass deutschland bereit ist seinen teil
zur stärkung der internationalen
zusammenarbeit beizutragen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache